what does it feel like to make history
i mean we were all a part of history so
it's pretty incredible unbelievable
incredible it was uh it was it was
something special i think it's a moment
that we'll all cherish
winning what does it mean to you it
means everything um i came to this game
one to do anything and everything i
could to make sure that big brother
season 23 would be remembered would be
remembered as crowning the first black
winner in bb us history um fortunately
that was me but if it was tiffany if it
was hannah kai big d or aza i'd have
been just as happy i know my family's a
little more happy that i did
um but it means everything the season
was about representation and
the season was also about a brotherhood
that we started on day one and it worked
all the way through until day 85.
and um we played the game well i
wouldn't have won this game without
everyone sitting beside me and um i
never want to lose sight of that so i'm
indebted to all of them first of all can
we solve the riddle who really came up
with the idea of talk to them too
talk to them
between uh come on
derek f definitely came around to all of
us on day one
um we all saw each other and knew i
definitely looked at everyone and was
like okay well i cannot target these
people i'm not going to be the one to do
it but derek did come around to each of
us and say hey you know we're working
together right so we all work together
and i believe xavier was the one that
came up with the name the cookout i'll
take that i'll take that credit yeah
oh i i had thought it was big d and
xavier because those were who came up to
me um and i knew the xavier came with
the name and big d did come around and
talk to everyone so um but it was a
mission that we all did feel in the
bottom of our hearts we came to the
house but it was brought to fruition you
know i don't think a lot of people
understand that you walk in a room and
you see other black and brown folks and
you just kind of like look at each other
and you're like okay
was that what happened
i literally like walked up to xavier and
he was just like you already know i was
like
okay that was it that was the whole
thing i would say that the celebration
this year was different than any other
year because everybody was happy there
were you know normally there's some
bitterness there's somebody standing on
the side like if i could go and stab him
right now
but there was a happiness and did you
feel that from all the contestants about
xavier's win but also about the cookout
absolutely absolutely yeah yeah
yes i think even though xavier was the
grand prize winner all six of us
especially with the cookout were winners
on day 65 when we were all there and it
was the six of us and our mission was
accomplished that was the win for all of
us regardless of who won the grand prize
although it would have been nice but
we all felt like winners at that moment
i think that we understand the reason
and other people have stepped up to
refute this but there have been a lot of
articles and comments saying that the
cookout was reverse racism what would
you say i'm gonna ask you what would you
say well the first thing i'm gonna say
is um reverse racism does not exist it's
literally impossible to happen um the
second thing i'm going to say is if
people do feel bad i would like them to
ask those questions to the jurors who
met us with nothing but love when we all
met them and
at the final time and jury
we all came here with what we said was a
mission
it wasn't based off of okay you're black
get out no it was based off of we would
like to achieve an african-american
winner to be achieved in history and
the fact that it resonated with so many
people beyond
color creed origin and everything just
speaks to show that this wasn't a season
about setting a division it was the
season about showing the powerfulness of
unity and what can happen when we all
work together
beautiful there have also been 22
seasons of alliances
that was i mean to simplify we could
simply say we were an alliance now
granted the reason that brought us
together transcended the game but when
you're in an alliance in the big brother
house your goal is to get out every
other person who's not in that alliance
and that was what we did just for the
record buy a unanimous vote can you see
xavier xavier exactly
you want you got all nine votes xavier
all right were you surprised by the jury
vote d
um no i didn't sign up today i wasn't
signed up for that i knew xavier
deserved to win i just felt like hey i'm
just trying to get sick plays man that's
all but i was not surprised because um
you know i never got a chance to really
say what i did i wasn't there in jury to
talk to everyone so i you know i had a
minute and i was like i don't know how
to say everything um also because the
cookout did not have meetings we did not
have group meetings but like hey i'm
doing this this is what i'm doing this
is what you're doing because we knew we
all couldn't get together so we were
working in twos and threes and
whispering down the lane and playing
telephone so um i think it was just one
of those things where hey i wasn't i
wasn't surprised i knew xavier won if i
had a key i would have turned to for him
too
yeah i'm like yeah man i would have
turned the key for him he definitely
i'ma tell y'all now run and get that
copyright get that copy right because
i'm trying to tell you i can get some
documents together everyone will want to
come to the cookout after this yes how
are you going to manage who gets
membership in the cookout or i don't
cook i was a cooking club i was a
cooking i have nothing
no i call simple meals remember that
yeah you got your boiled burgers
chop vegetables chopped vegetables and
do dishes i do dishes yeah she washes i
drive i will support emotionally yeah
never helped out never helped out he
just never it ain't about me no he's
never thought about us about us
all of us
he did
the cook of the century i wanted to try
to keep up with her but it was
impossible he literally did you win what
did you do i kept you from tearing him
apart
a great mastermind moves and slides in
between all groups and handles things
and that's what he did
i think tiffany had had her own hand
being the mastermind this season and i
want to make sure credit is given yeah
yes no she played the game amazing
absolutely amazing i think a lot of
people were surprised i thought she was
going to make it through the end yes
yeah but kylan had a different plan
didn't he yeah he did
wait what just happened
i'm sorry i just want to say for the
future when it comes to alliance sit
down and say what you did so you never
had to worry about this because when we
worked in that secret code it was like
oh i did this but i don't know you did
that and it was pretty difficult to say
who did what and only certain people
knew things so
um make sure you sit down and actually
say this is what i did but that can be a
that can put a target on you too you
don't really want to say what you did
because when you said you created the
master plan i was like see i'm not a
threat
[Laughter]
and in my head i was like
i was like come on tiffany came to my
room with the chess board and said here
we go i was like
but big d
okay i'm gonna let you off and i'm gonna
just sit here i was like i didn't do
anything so i am not a threat i was like
just left and then you know to be like
this is the plan and then i was like
well you know and then ozzy was trying
to get in and say something i was like
nope tiffany let tiffany come with the
plan and let's just go with it so let me
ask you this for future people of color
especially they're coming to the house
what's your advice what's your advice
right so what's the advice
okay you entertain yes if you are on an
island stay on that yes stay on that
island throw all
cookout is ordered you can only have one
cookout it only happens once sorry one
time and never be in the room with
someone that looked like you you say oh
there's two of us i gotta go i gotta go
i gotta go no more
one two yep
[Music]
you